okay so for our value proposition we're
simply gonna fill in mores template our
first line is four we're thinking about
our target customers here so who's your
target segment or persona can we have
who so our target customer is blank now
what is the remain problem that our
company is solving for so this is where
you write in their problem or their need
our product or service is blank now this
is where you describe the product or the
solution you want to categorize this
generally remember this is not the
differentiation line then we have that
provides what is your primary benefit to
your customer what is your solution to
their problem cite your breakthrough
capability here and the main benefit
that the customer receives next we have
unlike this is where you want to
reference your competition now you're
not trying to compare a michelin-star
restaurant to a subway here this is a
real alternative to your business and
finally our product or solution blank
this is where you state your primary
differentiation with your competitor
this is your key point of competitive
differentiation not every way that
you're different and some consider this
last line optional so taken together the
template is for your target customers
who what is their main problem then you
state your product or services describe
the solution or your product but don't
differentiate and what is it that you
provide for your customer unlike who's
your main competition and what is it
that differentiates you from that
competition this is a simple framework
but really helps you clearly define your
product and where you fit against a
competitor now I want you to take the
time to fill this out yourself I want
you to fill in the blanks to complete
your value proposition you can use your
own app idea or you can try to fill it
in using the abarkment idea